das was mich in diesen Tagen umtreibt
ist dass wir als Staat der Staat selbst
immer wieder von den Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern in dieser schwierigen Zeit
Sparmaßnahmen verlangt jeder muss den
Gürtel enger schneiden nur der Stadt ist
nicht in der Lage bei sich selbst
genauer hinzuschauen und deshalb haben
wir vorgeschlagen zu prüfen inwieweit
gerade ästhetische Beleuchtung hier in
der Hauptstadt
reduziert oder gar abgeschaltet werden
kann das kann sein die Reichstagskuppel
nach 0 Uhr im Licht zu dem das Rote
Rathaus in Berlin abzuschalten oder aber
auch das Brandenburger Tor in einer
reduzierten Beleuchtung und damit dazu
beizutragen denjenigen denen dieser
Krise Unterstützung durch den Start
brauchen über ein energiehilfsfonds
tatsächlich Hilfe zukommen zu lassen das
was der Staat von uns Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern erwartet das muss ja auch bei
sich selbst leisten und hier ernsthaft
prüfen wie viel bringt das wie viel
Stromersparnis bringt 1000 Euro wenn ich
nicht mehr 10.000 Euro sage ich Ihnen
das ist ja nicht deswegen ist das so
eine reine
eine reine Veranstaltung für den Show
ich bin da sehr man kann das machen wenn
man sagen will ich will ein Signal
aussenden das ist in Ordnung aber wir
sollten doch jetzt das nicht überhöhen
und sagen damit sparen wir Energie damit
mit führen wir die Bürger doch hinter
die Fichte wir müssen den doch sagen wo
die wirklichen Probleme unserer
Energiewirtschaft liegen doch nicht
daran dass wir ein bisschen Licht am
Licht ist das geringste Problem mit
Deutschland ja also ich ich muss jetzt
leider Gottes sagen jetzt schade des
Gang ist für mich wie Kabarett es tut
mir leid sie haben angefangen der Staat
muss den Gürtel enger schneiden dachte
ich ach wunderbar die Zahl der
parlamentarischen Staatssekretäre wird
reduziert die hohe Zahl der Beamten die
gerade unter Ampel noch mal aufgestockt
werden sind ins Uferlose der Bundestag
wird jetzt endlich mal kleiner die
Verwaltung wird geringer die Bürokratie
wird abgebaut vielleicht verdient sogar
ein paar Minister mal weniger wer auch
mal ein Zeichen aber Gürtel enger
schnallen des Staates und darin bestehen
würde weil ich Gürtel enger Schneiden
des Staates soll darin bestehen dass der
Staat das Geld das ihm nicht gehört wer
weniger Strom ausgibt ein öffent die
Gebäuden das ist doch lächer das ich
habe gesagt der Staat erwartet und es
ist ja auch so jeder jeder prüft der
gerade selbst in seinem eigenen Haushalt
das ja von dem gerade sie können doch
sich die Landesregierung anschauen in
unterschiedlichsten Konstellationen sie
können sich Bundesregierung nehmen
meinetwegen die ampelregierung auf
Bundesebene aber eine andere
Landesregierung überall bei wie viel es
noch Spaß beantworten da meine zweiten
sind wir doch in der Situation dass
jeder für sich prüft wo keiner einsparen
wie geht der quasi mit seinem
Haushaltseinkommen um wo kann ich diese
Krise ist unser Steuergeld die Frage
Einkommen wenn man ein energiehilfsfond
wie beispielsweise hier in Berlin mit
380 Millionen auflegt und sagt wir
wollen denjenigen die in dieser harten
Krise es nicht schaffen können aufgrund
ihrer Haushaltssituation die das Mehr an
Energiekosten zu zahlen auch staatlich
unter den Armen greifen dann kann man
das mit einer weiteren Neuverschuldung
tun was ich für falsch halte das heißt
oder man überprüft staatlicher wo haben
wir ausgabesituation und das ist zum
Beispiel die ästhetische Beleuchtung an
sie denn jetzt ein entscheiden
die Zahl bringe ich Ihnen nächste Woche
mit wir rechnen das Feld
10.000 Euro ich halte dagegen ich halte
sehr klein indem sie nehmen die gesamte
öffentliche Beleuchtung und machen
sozusagen Berlin insgesamt dicht und
dass die Leute abends nicht mehr sicher
aber die Straße gehen können und dann
reden wir natürlich über 3 Millionen den
Vorschlag den ich ab es wäre natürlich
10.000 Euro den Vorschlag wenig ab weil
wir brauchen hier eine differenzierte
Debatte über die Frage was ist
sicherheitsrelevant und was ist
ästhetische Beleuchtung und diese Frage
die muss in diesen Tagen doch wohl
zulässig sein darüber zu diskutieren
aber keine Personen der Stadt besteht
aus Personen und wenn dann leuchtendes
Beispiel abgeben will und
einführungszeichen leuchtendes Beispiel
da müssen die Staats Bediensteten auch
mal vorangehen es gibt viele sogar Herr
Habig beschwert sich sogar auf einmal
dass er zu viel Geld verdient wer hält
ihn davon ab davon was abzugeben wenn
halten Bundeskanzler Abgeordneter
Steuern
zahlen einfach Geld da rein machen aber
wenn es jetzt eine funzelbeleuchtung ist
am Brandenburger Tor das ist doch gut
wir fahren heute halten Sie das für
Symbolpolitik jetzt das Brandenburger
Tor schwarz zu machen
wir gehen sozusagen im Bundestag stimmt
die FDP gegen die Laufzeitverlängerung
der der Kernkraftwerke und jetzt kommt
kein Deutsch mit der Beleuchtung am
Brandenburger Tor das ist doch
lächerlich Mensch nehmen Sie doch sie
können doch den Funkturm nehmen sie
können den Fernsehturm neben Berlin ist
doch ein wunderbares Festival of Lights
durchgängig 365 Tage im Jahr ja super
und es ist doch legitim diese Frage zu
stellen ob sie irgendwo reduzieren oder
nicht aber versetzen sie sind Bürger
dann nicht für eigentlich wenig Ertrag
in ein absoluten krisenmodus also mich
würde das ängstigen wenn plötzlich alles
dunkel ist oder was würde sie denn
machen so um 2 Uhr daran ängstigen wenn
weniger Beleuchtung auf dem Roten
Rathaus wäre als jetzt nach Brandenburg
schon gerne das Brandenburger Tor war
jetzt das Beispiel an einem Spieler aber
wir können ja mit Augenmaß mal diese
Frage willst du noch weniger als 10.000
Euro nein ich halte dagegen ich halte
komplett dagegen
aber Paul in wenigen Tagen Klarheit über
diese Frage haben wie viel das in der
Stadt Berlin ausmacht Augsburg macht es
doch auch wir haben andere gemeinsam
und sich mit diesen Fragen
auseinandersetzen diese Energiekonzepte
müsste ich Ihnen sagen die werden bei
den ganzen deutschen Volk wirklich
zeigen wie lächerlich sich mittlerweile
Politik macht wir fragen einmal
paronsheimer vielleicht ist ja einer in
der Runde der dem Vorschlag was
abgewinnen kann
sicherlich symbolisch kann man das
machen ich blau finde tatsächlich auch
dass die FDP sich mehr Gedanken darüber
machen sollte wie sie es schafft in der
Ampel die
das Thema Atomenergie aus Programm zu
bringen und zu sagen dass das länger
läuft aber gut jetzt sind sie in der
Berliner Landespolitik
wenn man machen schadet niemanden glaube
ich wirklich Symbol als Symbol
ich glaube schon dass wir irgendwann
darüber sprechen werden wo wir eventuell
verzichten müssen oder wo die Menschen
sich einschränken müssen ich glaube
sicherlich dass das passieren kann und
dann kann es ein Symbol sein
eine Berechnung gesehen aus Berlin das
trifft sie jetzt nicht weil es hier in
der Opposition sind natürlich Millionen
wurden verschleudert indem man einfach
die Corona Abrechnungen von diesen
Teststationen nicht geprüft hat
Millionen wurden verschleudert und es
war ein Betrug mit Ansagen wir als FDP
raus ja absolut da bin ich ja sehr dafür
das macht eine gute konservative
Opposition wunderbar vielleicht bekommt
ihn die Ampel nicht so gut also das ist
so Wahnsinn der Start verschleudert Geld
mit Ansage im Milliardenbereich und dann
ist dann auch nichts gewonnen wenn er da
mal für 5 Minuten sagt so jetzt nehmen
wir mal als Bücher gehand über und geh
mal kurz dunkel über den Platz sie haben
ja heute auch noch ein Thema mitgebracht
also nochmal es geht ja nicht um dunkel
ne es geht um die Frage der
Verhältnismäßigkeit darauf zu schauen
und ich halte dagegen und sage es ist
wesentlich mehr als sie jetzt mit ihren
10.000€
nicht gut wenn sie nicht mal wissen was
sie bewirken das sozusagen über das
deutsche Fernsehen ins Volk zu bringen
weil sie am Ende damit etwas suggerieren
es sind ganz einfach ist doch ganz
einfach Energie zu sparen ich sage Ihnen
das bringt gar nichts Licht bringt gar
nichts was Sie machen müssen ist
wirklich dann ganz anders an die
Energieeinsparung heranzugehen und da
reden wir dann wirklich über mega was
und nicht über Kilowattstunden die sie
jetzt alles
zeigen wir
aber ihre Aussage jetzt halte ich für
sehr relevant weil sie sie tun ja so als
dürfte man keine Debatten Beiträge
machen dürfen Sie gerne wenn sich
lächerlich machen darüber diskutieren
das ist doch genau das Problem der
vergangenen Zeiten dass wir denkt Tabus
hatten über die Frage wie können wir an
Dinge herangehen und deshalb ist es in
die mattenbeitrag machen die großen
Früchte und und ich habe die kleinen
Erdnüsse es geht nicht um die Frage wie
können wir in Deutschland dem Problem
Herr werden sondern es ging darum wie
können wir auf der einen Seite mehr
Schulden in der Stadt im Land Berlin
vermeiden weil wir genau wissen dass
alles was wir Schulden finanziert tun
und alles was wir an an Paketen am Rhein
gehen am Ende auch zu Lasten der
zukünftigen Generation geht und noch
dazu im übertragenen Sinne zum
Inflationstreiber wird also können wir
doch auf der anderen Seite bitte über
sinnvolle Maßnahmen schauen und die
staatlichen Ausgaben so in den Griff
kriegen dass wir auf der anderen Seite
Elektroautos in Berlin abstimmen das
würde viel mehr bringen aber erfahren
Leute damit hat er entscheiden natürlich
recht jeder Debatten Beitrag dafür
gemacht werden